But before we go to raid let's
see if we understood what codes,
especially parity can do for us.
Suppose we are using parity to detect
bit-flip errors in our dram memory.
Our unprotected memory
has eight one bit arrays,
each of which is 1024 by 1024 bits.
So we have eight small arrays.
Each of these arrays is given
the same row and column address and
each of these arrays outputs one
bit of the overall eight bit value
that we're trying to read or
write in this memory.
We want to use parity to
detect bit flips, and
what we can afford is a parity bit for
every group of four data bits.
The question for
you is whether we should add two more
one-bit arrays of this kind for parity.
So the idea is that we would
add another array here,
and the bit stored here would be the
parity for the first four bits here and
another one would store the parity for
these four data bits.
Or should we add these additional
parity bits every row in each array?
So that we don't need the extra modules
but what we do is we extend each of
these modules with the extra bits
that protect the data in that row.
Note that the overall number of bits
that we add is the same in these two
approaches.
The question for
you is which one is better?